I mean what I am also surprised about is
him putting uh voice of the distance
star yeah the fuckz like what is this
thing so this was this is shinkai
Makoto's first directorial debut it was
a what was it like it was a short film I
think it was like 20 30 minutes or
something uh kind of Mecca but also
including a lot of like the shinkai isms
of like you know lots of emotional
scenes and stuff like that it does have
a good soundtrack to be fair does it I
don't I don't remember I I remember I
remember the soundtrack being pretty
good but the problem is is that I barely
remember the plot because cuz it was
[__] cuz it was not very good cuz Mako
Shinko didn't learn how to do plots
until your name uh is he the director
who keeps making the same movie or is
that okay weathering with you 5 cm per
second okay I mean that's a very
generalization I said but that's it
generally makes it generally makes very
similar things yeah no I cuz I remember
you're not going to believe it his next
film is a romance
okay I could have figured that one out
well it's he does like different
variations but I remember before your
name
yeah different variations it's almost
more insulting I think you're saying
yeah he just he does the same thing he
changes it up sometimes his I actually
watched his newest film over Christmas
and it was like oh the the the scissor
yeah um that was kind of felt like
shinkai was like I'm going to try making
a gibli film that's that's what it felt
like and then there was romance in there
and that that was the part that actually
was the weirdest part because before he
did mirror which was another one that no
no that's uh that's uh the other
director before that he did what's the
other rad Wim [__] thing weathering
with you weathering with you yeah I
liked weathering with you yeah a lot of
people like that movie I I prefer to
have your name I hav I did not yeah but
you're [__] you have a boner for your
name so I just think that he like here's
the thing um about shinkai cuz I am a
big fan of shinkai and I'm very familiar
with I've watched everything that he's
put out um something that was always
strong in his Works pre your name was
that he always had a he always I could
always tell the idea and the emotions
and the feeling that he wanted to put
across in his films like that was always
something that really resonated with me
no matter what shink I did including
voice of a distant Star as well um and
the thing that I always thought he was
missing was he would always have this
idea or emotion that would resonate with
me but the plot would always be [__]
boring you know it would yeah in my in
my opinion in my opinion it was more
like you know cuz my favorite shinkai
film is 5 cm per second but not because
I think it has like a really good plot
it's more so the fact that like sh as
you said like shinkai's movies a lot of
the times were not like a singular story
that was being told it was kind of just
like a collection of emotions just like
kind of stitched together yeah I mean 5
C per second I think it's a beautiful
idea for a story but there's no story
but what's the story there's no story
what's what is is the compelling like
plot line of that you know and why is it
called 5 cm per second cuz that's how
fast it felt the story was going no it's
called 5 cm/ second because that's the
speed at which a cherry blossom pedal
Falls that's legitimately white it's
called 5 cm per second cuz the the the
cherry blossom falling Motif is used a
lot in that movie yeah but I I feel like
he discovered like he he discovered
something with your name where he took
all of these some of these ideas and
emotions and he weaved it into what I
thought was a pretty compelling plotline
and I thought that was the only piece of
the puzzle he was missing sure and then
he found that with your name and then he
was like I don't know how to do
something else other than some kind of
like the same kind of ideas is that um
so like one thing I respect about Suz is
that he tried something new it's it's
definitely different from weathering
with you that's good um he I would have
liked more if it actually did not have
any romance in it funnily enough you
were asking shinkai to not do yeah yeah
I I thought that was the least
interesting part of that plot uh it's
like asking light novel authors to not
do incest not going to happen well well
funnily enough I also thought the
romance part you guys have seen your
name right yeah I thought I also thought
The no you never seen your name
no I I I've had I've had this struggle
honestly with watching uh anything
romance related in anime yeah um and I I
don't have this problem with normal uh
like Western media I I just F I don't
know what it is about Japanese Japanese
interpretation Japanese interpretation
of romance stories that I just don't
connect with really a lot of them I just
don't care about I'm completely the
opposite I I see I see a western romance
story and I'm like you know it's just
like except the notebook notebook is
Banger it is it's my favorite
unironically it is my favorite Western
romance
film like all these women [__] cry
about like oh Titanic is the most
[__] blah blah I'm like no it's just
a [__] ship syn that kind of that
kind of romance I don't really [__]
care about much either that's like very
that's very like angelical Christian
interpretation of romance everything is
if this is a hot take but the notebook
gave me the feeling of a Japanese
interpreted
Romance I'm s
I'm in the sense that it's like if if
the notebook ever got an anime
adaptation I could totally see Shen Kai
doing it because it gives that I it
gives that same feeling of like the
notebook having this like it has you
know unlike a lot of shinkai films it
does have this coherent story but
there's so many different emotional
points that feel very shinkai in the way
that like how the characters change and
develop and stuff like that I mean like
for one it's just a really solidly
written story in my opinion um I think
the only reason why it's had this stigma
is because it's the [__] relationship
tester movie that everyone talks about
right but when I actually finally sat
down and watch it with Aki I was like
wow that was actually a [__]
beautiful movie I I cried in the
notebook bro like I think I watched the
notebook too it it was a great film um I
too watched it and it was I don't
remember much about it it wasn't
Japanese I didn't feel anything you know
Chang Tatum was good in it sorry Chang
Tatum was good in it Chang Tatum isn't
it Chang Tatum it's not Channing tat who
is it it's not Ryan goling it's uh wait
was there another movie around that time
with with Channing Tatum that I wait it
was Ryan goling wasn't it was it Ryan
goling was it Ryan goling I just I just
kind of like it's that guy I just kind
of like
what's the guy yeah it's R go [__] there
must been I got cuz I remember I was
dating this girl and she forced me to
watch like three of these films and I
they all blended into one my Tatum in it
at that time I swear 21 Jump Street no
no I swear there's a movie cuz before 21
Jump before Chan tat was a comedy actor
he was doing romance only was he do you
remember this no I remember this yeah
channy Tatum was the romance I think I
found out about channy Tatum through 21
jum stre that that that was when he
started to like are you serious that was
when he started to like pivot but before
when he wanted to like was the American
like romance goto heart really wow I did
not know that um that's why he did a
bunch of weird films try and kind of get
out of that notion um what what American
or what western Rance stories you like
and I when I said this out loud and I
know that we were talking about it I was
trying to think in my head cuz I knew
you going to ask me this and I'm trying
to think of a piece of media that I
think did romance really well oh um
what's the [__] Jim Carrey one uh
Eternal Spotless Mind Eternal Spotless
Mind that's a romance
technically I I love and and I I swear I
feel like I I haven't seen this ever in
a in a and maybe that you can correct me
cuz I I'd love to be wrong about this uh
there's rarely ever stories about
romance going horribly wrong that's why
I like my [__] romances man no yours
doesn't go horribly wrong I think I
think what is talking about is that it
seems like it's going in the right
direction and then it ends up going
horribly wrong because the protag as it
so does in life what are you what are
you talking about your is what are you
talking I stuck my dick in my little
sister your one is your one your one
your one goes wrong from minute one no
no it doesn't go wrong from okay this is
this is this is a horrible example right
but I really [__] love how they deal
with romance and Peep
Show where are you [__] serious this
[__] mess of a a comp cuz cuz romance
is super messy in real life that's one
step away from the [__] Dennis system
that's so that's so [__] up but
there's I I love the whole Arc with like
Mark getting married in CU in this Peep
Show he gets married to this woman that
he doesn't really know if he wants to
get married to but he just thinks it's
the right thing to do and then he
realizes it's [__] horrible idea and
he didn't want to get married and I kind
of love that they did a story that like
in in West media we can have a bunch of
these stories about stuff like that I
feel like in anime there would never be
a show like that there would never be a
show where a guy gets married turns out
he doesn't like his wife and it but and
and they would commit to it in a way
that would actually make you think hold
on these guys are horrible people uh it
would make you think like oh his wife is
a a Demon Lord that's why he doesn't
like her it's like nothing we they can
never make an like just unlikable
characters that we can figure out that
we don't like it's like hey this is a
character you shouldn't like it's
because I think it's because it just
hits too close to home for japanes
that's what I want but Japanese don't
want how many how many Japanese people
right are in [__] Loveless marriages
why can't we get a [__] a love Mar
that's why shows like aetco was so not
popular in Japan because it's too close
to home and Japanese people don't want
to watch isn't that crazy that it was
about [__]
animals like w this is too real but they
were still but they were still like yo
Haida is totally me dog this guy said he
doesn't like work I don't okay no I'm
based on what you said I'm going to say
something [__] outrageous okay all
right [__] you want escapism no [__]
rent a girlfriend man that is almost
exactly without without the marriage
part but with the everyone being
[__] yeah but here's where you're
going to lose him they're all high
schoolers well okay know University
students actually they're all University
students but it's the suspension of
disbelief is to a degree where I'm like
ah I think this is just this is silly
but I think if there was it was grounded
in some some reality like how come every
single godamn love triangle in an anime
has to be so corny and stupid why can't
it be an actual love triangle like what
you mean where they have to actually
like how the they would have to actually
explore the mechanics of what it would
actually mean to have to juggle this
realistic love triangle and how fck up
it would be why that's why golden time
is one of my favorite romances cuz I did
exactly that in my opinion that's
probably the most realistic depiction of
a love triangle um not they also did
that in Ichigo 100% I think the problem
is that also a lot of the times if if
you were to really depict an actual love
triangle you probably wouldn't like the
protagonist much MH yeah and then you
end up with school days yeah so how do
you how do you juggle that but I feel
like that could be like and why golden
time is so compelling mhm because it it
tries to do something different and
doesn't play the safe rot of in the
romance here here's what's going to
happen here's are the two people going
to get together it's all going to be
very happy oh maybe you know and and my
my my pet peeve is that they're like
this romance is tough or how do we how
do we throw some spice into this romance
and make it it kind of difficult I don't
know [__] kill that kid or kill
someone else around them that makes them
have to be sad as opposed to having some
actual problems stem from their romance
like let's make the problem come from an
out like an outward Source not not
something that they're having to deal
with and I feel like that's a much more
mature way of approaching romance that
we are a little more inclined to
exploring in a western way but that's I
I don't think we do as like a good job
either uh but I feel like we just do not
get this flat out at all in anime and
that's kind of the reason why I'm not
too huge into anime romance anime yeah I
think just in general everything you
describe I don't everything to be
depressing by the way I'm say I would
like actually uh give me give me more
depressing romance
stories I think the reason for it works
for me in anime is because there is that
suspension of disbelief uh because I
think I have a lot of the same problems
that you have with romance except when I
see real actors I'm like this isn't this
ain't real this this is like some no no
when when I see real actors uh that
brings it out uh brings me out of the
story even more because because with
anime it's like a animated medium
something in my brain just just thinks
okay you have a higher suspension of
disbelief just because you know that
this is kind of like a fantasy cartoon
world but when I see real actors and
something doesn't replicate real life
how I know it that actually makes the
intricacies of what doesn't work that's
crazy I come out even more for me I feel
the opposite cuz I feel like when I'm
watching a movie and there's some really
talented actors uh and just seeing all
the little body language that they're
doing to really sell this emotion or
what they're thinking uh I think that's
just say we just you cannot replicate in
anime because you can't have all these
tiny little body movements they all have
to be deliberate whereas an actor can
kind of put in these little maybe an arm
movement maybe a tongue in the like
literally like I don't know you know
like little really tiny little body
movements that we just can't express in
anime that can really sell an emotion or
a scene or doubt well I I would go the
opposite way where you know animation is
a different form where you can express a
certain idea or a certain Motion in a
different way than any real actor can
you know you can draw Expressions you
can exaggerate movement and emotions
without making it feel like it's out of
place just because it takes place in a
world of cartoon so it's I think I think
it totally for me it's I'm kind of in
between you guys where for me it just
totally depends on the actual story that
is taking place I think some stories
works better in animation absolutely
some stories work better in live action
and I don't really have a preference
generally prefer liveaction stuff for
romance just because I find that those
very slight body movements really sell
romance you know the the little things I
had that feeling when I watched the
anime version of I want to eat your
pancreas and then I watched the live
action version of it I way prefer the
live action version of it because of
what you said where you can add a lot
more to it yeah there's like the feeling
of the emotion was just so much more
potent with real people as opposed to
the anime but I would absolutely want
more in anime than oh totally um just
how it goes interesting yeah um um other
than that though I mean Ghost in the
Shell Akira amazing soundtracks totally
get it uh the Lugia movie I guess that's
just Nostalgia for Kevin um Pokemon was
ente was the third one right uh ente was
the third was the third that one was
pretty good but I remember not being as
solid as the other two but I know a lot
of people love the ente movie yeah and
the celby movie as well that one and
then there's the unknown movie The
Unknown wasn't there a movie about the
unknowns Pokemon am I crazy I don't know
I haven't seen all of is there a movie I
swear there's a movie about the unknowns
and then [__] I think the last
Lucario got his own movie luar movie I
think the last one I actually remember
watching was oh maybe it was oh yeah it
might have been the third third one the
unknown cuz I think the unknown played a
huge part in that movie the last one I
watched was the celby movie that was a
good movie too that was great then there
was a was there a Latios and Latias one
yeah [__] me bro they printed money pred
money and good well solid solid list
from Kevin uh definitely this is your
composer's favorite anime kind of list
uh is that Ghost in the Shell the movie
it is yeah it is the movie I haven't
watched a movie Only the series it's
good it's not doesn't matter everything
about Ghost in the Shell no matter what
except for maybe the live action movie
Everything slaps pretty hard as oh yeah
about the 2045 the new one oh I don't we
don't talk yeah we don't talk about okay
I forgot about that one the back
flipping up the stairs still my favorite
if it's a ghost and the shell like anime
anime yeah like an actual anime still my
favorite scene ever when the guy gets
all his money from getting the one yen
from Bank transaction my favorite scene
ever so good all right good job Kevin
good job all right